if you went to bed thinking okay we
don't have our results and you woke up
like I did
okay now I'll turn on the TV no still
it's just zero zero zero zero across the
lot of zeros on the board today welcome
to CBS this morning and that's where we
begin the only results from the Iowa
caucuses at this hour are chaos and
confusion never good here are the
numbers as we said right now they are
the zeros there it is Anthony all across
the board CBS News cannot declare a
winner because there ain't any results
exactly right Iowa's Democratic Party
has not released the final count because
they don't have it we expected though
later today the party says in a
statement we found inconsistencies in
the reporting of three sets of results
CBS News is also being told the party
did not fully test its new reporting
systems in some areas now after the
caucuses but before any kind of official
count came in candidates rallied their
supporters and mayor Pete Budaj and
senator Bernie Sanders both seemed to
claim victory overnight other candidates
withheld judgment until that final call
comes in this morning most of the
candidates have moved on to New
Hampshire where the first-in-the-nation
primary is just one week away let's go
to chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett who is outside Democratic
headquarters in Des Moines major I want
to ask you what happened but it seems
like the story is no one really knows
what happened so tell us about these
inconsistencies the party found well
let's try to figure out what that
actually means nobody knows the state
party is not explaining what even
consistencies mean what we do know is it
pledged to count and then report three
different set of numbers the first
number everyone's first caucus choice
upon entering the second that
realignment number into third delegates
won by each cannon well the state party
says it's still trying to verify crunch
all those numbers before it's
comfortable in reporting them we should
also note the state party as mentioned
was trying out a brand new system this
year one that appears to have been
overwhelmed and not tested thoroughly
enough one problem the telephone app did
not work as imagine that's putting it
mildly so this morning the two chief
political exports of Iowa are
uncertainty and embarrassment
we know there's delays but we know one
thing we are punching above
waise Democratic contenders shocked by
the lack of results rallied their
supporters to cheer what might be by the
time it's all said and done Iowa you
have shocked the nation when those
results are announced I have a good
feeling we're going to be doing very
very well but the mess and I will means
the battle for the Democratic nomination
has stumbled out of the gate I gotta say
I'm a numbers guy we're still waiting on
numbers from tonight Iowa Democrats were
stunned and confused
the results were delayed
[Music]
reason given in the end like there are
numbers so where are the freaking
precinct chairs reported glitches with
an app that was supposed to be used to
send results to the party
Tina Weber precinct secretary of Waukee
too said she had to rely on other
methods we couldn't have people waiting
in that room packed in hot just because
app wasn't working with those who tried
to call in their results experienced
long holds thank you for calling the
Iowa Democratic Party's caucus hotline
all of our representatives are currently
busy in a statement the Iowa Democratic
Party said this was simply a reporting
issue the app did not go down and there
is not a hack or an intrusion the day
before the caucus we asked eight party
Chairman Troy Price if you had any fear
about tech glitches or other problems do
you have a nightmare scenario and if so
what do you do about it these are
probably the most prepared we've ever
been as a party for these caucuses and
we've run through a few different
scenarios but I can tell you we're ready
former presidential candidate Julian
Castro now a supporter of Senator Warren
said the delay proves one thing
Dallas County Democratic party chair
Bryce Smith tried to put the best face
on things
it's better to get the information right
the first time then - three days later
go well actually you know this is what
happened but as the night wore on
candidates shifted their attention to
the next contests well major it sounds
like Troy price we need to reevaluate
his assessment of their readiness
they're in Iowa but I got a question for
you about about the voters that he gave
up their evening to go out and caucus
how are they feeling today well everyone
wants to know what happened and think
about this the candidates didn't come
here to campaign for the Iowa caucuses I
mean that's what they came to campaign
for not the to be determined caucuses
and for the voters thousands of whom
showed up to these caucuses for the very
first time this is not what they
expected certainly not what they
promised so the Iowa Democratic Party
better get its act together and soon if
it's going to claim any legitimacy in
this process not a good look for Iowa
not a little bit not a good look for the
Democrats major thank you very much
you